welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
Tony Tecopa with Gayle King and Anthony
Mason and we're going to begin with in
an exclusive interview Amazon were
responding to safety concerns
surrounding its massive fleet of
contractor delivery drivers there's an
ongoing investigation by ProPublica and
BuzzFeed news that found those drivers
have been involved in more than 60
crashes causing injuries or death since
June 2015
Amazon estimates it will have about
50,000 delivery vehicles on the road
during the holidays Lola lanky looked at
how the contractor vehicles are overseen
molla what'd you learn loga morning Tony
that joint investigation found that
drivers reported feeling tremendous
pressure to meet deadlines and that
Amazon often avoids liability for
accidents one family we spoke to who
lost their daughter in a crash with a
delivery driver said no life is worth a
package the backseat was sort of pushed
up into the front seat and her car seat
was tilted and I couldn't get her out
that way Chad and Ellen Kennedy's 10
month old daughter Gabrielle was killed
in January when a delivery driver hit
Ellen's car then my eyes went back to
the rearview mirror and that was when I
just saw the headlights according to the
ProPublica BuzzFeed news investigation
from September the driver was hauling
packages for an Amazon subcontractor
those contractors are often liable if
there's an accident not Amazon really
serious things that go wrong with these
deliveries it's never Amazon's problem
amazon has actually sued to enforce the
terms of these agreements
ProPublica senior reporter Patricia
Callahan says despite avoiding liability
Amazon has a tight grip on day-to-day
operations the company can even tell
drivers to turn left or right on a
particular route Amazon knows where they
are on the road it's telling them the
order in which they need to deliver each
package there's a dispatcher in an
Amazon warehouse that can check on their
progress and call them and say where are
you why isn't it there through work
orders Callahan found that Amazon
requires 999 out of 1,000 deliveries to
arrive on time Amazon refuted that claim
and said while they have expectations of
their drivers there are no quotas the
drivers overwhelmingly said talked about
the pressure that's on that drivers
talked about urinating in bottles
because they don't have time to stop and
use a bathroom Callahan says the driver
who hit Ellen Kennedy said he was
feeling pressured that day because he
was running behind but the contractor
who employed him refuted that in an
exclusive interview with CBS News Dave
Clark senior vice president of worldwide
operations at Amazon said safety when it
comes first
we're focused on background and driving
check to make sure that the people we
put in the vehicle come from a place of
a good driving record a good safety
record and then we train them before
they ever hit the road Clark highlighted
the technology they used to monitor
drivers actions as an added safety net
but sometimes Clark said accidents
happen when you drive 800 million miles
there will be accidents unfortunately
our focus is about how do you reduce
those how do we get our routing to
ensure that we're putting people into
into conditions to where they're not
having to back out of neighborhoods
they're not having to make as many
left-hand turns they're really not
having to rush through the course of the
day as for the candidates the father
told us they settled in a suit with the
contractor but they insist no dollar
amount could quell their grief there's
no price on my daughter
life but if I can save another family
from this tragedy and that that's the
reason why I I want to talk to people
now Amazon says that joint investigation
did not accurately represent the
company's commitment to safety in a
response to CBS News Amazon extended
condolences to the Kennedys and said if
a driver is struggling to complete their
shipments on a particular route guys it
will deploy resources to help them on
the course of that route
well the Kennedys are right no package
no deliveries worth anybody's life and
if it's true that Amazon says they put
safety first maybe they need to make
sure the drivers understand that yes he
or she felt pressured right Camus's on
says they have a whole system in place
to where rushing is not necessary they
strategically place
district
and centers and all that but ultimately
people are behind the wheel they
certainly make a lot of deliveries Mulla
thank you